feels weird
picking it up the legacy of that shield
is complicated
to say the least that shield should be
destroyed
this world is us we're never gonna stop
it's the closest thing i've got left to
a family
[Applause]
i'm not gonna let anybody tell me i
can't fight for now streaming
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
the falcon and the winter soldier
episode 3 comes in just
a few days marvel has given us a little
teaser of what's to come as you just saw
and there's a lot not shown in this that
is going to be coming in episode 3 as
well
when we last left off with falcon in the
winter soldier episode 2 it
ended on baron zemo and his return is
coming in episode 3.
so we're going to be talking about zemo
sharon carter who we have yet to see
super soldiers the flag smashers and of
course mutants
and we'll talk about when we think sam
is going to be getting that shield back
because it's very clear that at some
point in time he will be getting
captain america shield back for himself
and before we dive into it don't forget
to subscribe and hit the notification
bell so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos
now to start this video off there has
been a leak about the run time of
episode 3.
and according to a reddit user who has
been verified by the mods this is going
to be the longest falcon in the winter
soldier episode
yet coming in at 54 minutes so we're
already getting episodes that are longer
than the one division episodes but we
also have to keep in mind that the
falcon and the winter soldier is only
six episodes long with
episode three coming that's the halfway
mark we're halfway done with the series
but this is a good sign because that
means that episodes four
five and six coming up should be even
longer so we have a lot of the series
left now it's nice that the next episode
is going to be so long because we're
going to be introduced or should i say
reintroduced to baron zemo and we know
that falcon and bucky
are actually going to end up teaming up
with zemo
in this show at the end of episode 2
when sam and bucky are talking they say
they need to go to zemo to find out more
information about hydra and the super
soldier program
and right now he's in prison but as
we've seen from the trailers he gets out
and we also know that they end up
teaming up and we know why they're going
to team up they're going to team up
because of the super
soldiers in one of the trailers that we
got zema was very clear that his work
is unfinished and he has no intention on
leaving it unfinished
superheroes cannot be allowed
to exist
[Music]
i have no intention to leave my work
unfinished
so he says superheroes cannot be allowed
to exist
so clearly if hydra or another
organization of some sort
is giving terrorists the super soldier
serum and keeping the program alive
this goes directly against zemo's plans
to basically get rid of all of the
superheroes he doesn't want some evil
organization
creating new superheroes and clearly
bucky and sam don't want that either
so this is why they team up the enemy of
my enemy
is my friend will this last the entire
series though
well i think they have different plans
set up for zemo and i think it's going
to be a little bit more surprising than
we expect
when i spoke with the director of the
show carrie skoglyn and i asked her
about zemo this is what she had to say
you know you mentioned the brainwashing
and in bucky's past
zemo is a character that's going to be
returning and he's more of a complicated
character as well because he was a good
person
but due to you know such a tragic
incident that happened with his family
he is now set up for revenge we saw him
in civil war he took his revenge
went to prison now he's back what is it
like to direct somebody
a character like that that once was good
but is now so set on revenge is there
any hope for him
are there going to be different layers
to his character that we're going to see
throughout the show
well what i can tell you is uh whatever
it is you expect from him
um it won't happen so
it's always the unexpected with amc
uh yeah so she said whatever you expect
from him isn't going to happen and i
think right now what a lot of people
think
is going to happen is that he's actually
going to be bad and betray
sam and bucky so perhaps he's actually
going to be good somehow perhaps he's
just going to try and kill the super
soldier
program and all of the other super
soldiers and not go after sam and bucky
or any of the other good heroes
perhaps he comes to terms with the fact
that bucky was indeed
brainwashed into doing all those evil
things but is now good and there are
good heroes out there
but we then have another question when
it comes to zemo
in the trailer we see zemo with bucky
and sam in madrapore and this is
actually quite interesting because as
you probably know by now magipore is a
place that is ran by
mutants and the x-men some good some not
so good in the comics
in fact professor xavier's mansion and
some storylines in the comics is in
madripore it has a heavy connection with
wolverine and many other different
mutants as well
and of course the big question is why
are they here and why are they here with
zemo
well it would make sense that we kind of
start to see some mutants here i don't
think marvel is going to announce that
they are mutants but i think we're going
to see other people that are very
similar to super soldiers
yet aren't since bucky and sam are going
to zemo to talk about hydra and other
super soldiers out there i think zemo
might lead them to magipore because it's
a place where a lot of shady stuff
happens
and there's a lot of so-called super or
enhanced people
in magipore and if you cut my video a
couple of days ago
you've heard that malcolm spellman the
lead writer and creator of the show
has already addressed the fact that this
is indeed match report and the
repercussions of introducing this to the
mcu are
going to be big so clearly there is
something up in magipor and there's a
reason that zemo is actually leading
bucky and sam
to magipore there's clearly an
organization somewhere in majapur that
has something to do with super soldiers
or perhaps even mutants but again i
don't think they're really going to
address the mutants
in the falcon and the winter soldier
more like set them up for a future
project
now we did learn about another secret
cameo that is supposed to be an actual
secret cameo not just paul bettany
times two but an actual secret character
coming in episode five
malcolm spellman did share that the
fifth episode of the series is the one
that he is most excited for everybody to
see and he said that we're all going to
cry
he said hands down five it just gets
real
and five you're going to cry he went on
to say
there are characters in our series who i
would love to see partnered with like
it's a very very grounded character
partnered with one of the big world
shakers like thor
or someone like that the personality is
so strong it's the episode 5 character
i'd love to see that character with thor
so there is a new secret character
coming in episode 5 and perhaps he is
coming from magipor now i don't think
he's going to be a mutant or anyone
crazy like wolverine
but perhaps he could have some tie to
the mutants now magipoor is known for
being a very corrupt and criminal
centered city so perhaps the grc
who we believe are actually pretty
crooked and the power broker behind
everything are
somewhere in madrapore perhaps the base
of operations for the power broker could
be there maybe zemo knows this and maybe
that's why zemo takes them to madrid for
but we'll have to wait till episode 3 to
find out now another character that
isn't exactly confirmed for episode 3
but should be coming in the next episode
or
episode 4 is sharon carter we know that
she's going to pop up we know that she's
going to have a pretty decent role and
it looks like she's actually going to
manage to save bucky and sam at some
point
now she's been on the run ever since
civil war and unfortunately it doesn't
really seem like she's been pardoned yet
so perhaps once all the flax master
stuff started going down she started
tracking them and that's how she's going
to end up running into sam and bucky
and no doubt joined them in their
journey to figure out who was behind the
flag smashers the grc
and who the power broker is so a lot to
look forward to in the future episodes
of the falcon and the winter soldier a
lot to look forward to in the very
next episode episode 3 with the return
of
zemo if i hear about any more plot
details or leaks for the falcon in the
winter soldier i'll be sure to let
everybody know so don't forget to
subscribe and hit the notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos
meanwhile let me know what you think
about this video in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
you can always follow me on instagram
and twitter for live updates
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof